які були справжні місцеві заводи в
регіоні, таких планів НАТО не було, і
я думаю, що варто повернутися на
пару років до обрання президента Януковича Україна прагнула до
членства
в НАТО після того, як Янукович став
президентом, він заявив, що Україна
прагнутиме позаблокового статусу  і ми поважали
це рішення, яке ми завжди дуже чітко приймали,
що Україна вирішувала,
прагнути до членства чи ні, тоді
безлюдна підписала договір, який
надав використання порту Севастополя
ще на 40 років або 30 37 років, незалежно від того, що
було до 20 42 року.  і ми сказали добре,
що це ваш привілей, ми поважаємо ваші
суверенні рішення ідея про те, що НАТО
планувала захопити Севастополь
, як і історії про етнічні
чистки та жорстокість проти
російського населення Криму, все це
повна вигадка, що якщо Nate Russia
подасть заяву  що стати
членом НАТО це здається досить
малоймовірним у поточний період, але я
вважаю, що союзникам було б важко  повинні відповідати так
само, як і будь-якій іншій країні, чи
то маленька країна, як Чорногорія чи
Боснія і Герцеговина, які є серед наших
заявників, чи попередні більші країни,
як Польща та Румунія, у нас є
процес, який називається планом дій щодо членства,
який починається з посиленого
діалог, який би перш за все
досліджував інтереси Росії,
які її запропоновані внески в
Альянс, але у нас знову є процес,
мені здається дуже надуманою
можливістю в сьогоднішній період історії,
але якщо Росія зробила перехід на 180 градусів,
ми  є спосіб вирішити їхню
заявку, що спалах оголосив про наш
вроджений військовий літак
знову, це знову залежить від
обставин, що нас дуже хвилює,
це те, що деякі з дуже
агресивної поведінки російських пілотів,
які були зняті на чорну плівку  моря
з USS Donald Cook у Балтійському морі,
а нещодавно відбулося
подібне близьке зіткнення над Чорним
морем, існує ризик, що т  різні
події можуть призвести до випадкового
зіткнення або гірше, тому ми вважаємо, що нам потрібно
посилити правила дорожнього руху, щоб
краще керувати такими інцидентами, щоб було більше
передбачуваності, у нас є механізми для
зв’язку один з одним у режимі реального часу, якщо  стався
інцидент, щоб не було
ненавмисної ескалації, США та Росія,
звичайно, попри всі свої
розбіжності щодо Сирії,
принаймні досягли угоди щодо D, що
суперечить польотам їхніх
літаків саме для того, щоб уникнути інцидентів
у небі, тому головне – запобігти їм
управління наслідками було б
набагато більшим викликом